the virtual brainlink cable will now be
connected
this will hurt much more than it did in
training be
[Applause]
beginning
strong
cable connection
[Applause]
i'm okay
we can do this
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
so this
this is fine
i can handle it
good seems like you're okay
this aptitude test will determine your
platoon assignment
do your best
yes sir
the virtual brainlink cable will now be
connected
this will hurt much more than it did in
training be strong
systems all green beginning sas cable
connections
is this for real
[Music]
so this is what scs feels like
good seems like you're okay
this aptitude test will determine your
platoon assignment
do your best yes sir
identity confirmed the other suppression
force aptitude test will now begin
exterminate all others
[Applause]
[Music]
this test will decide my assignment
i hope i'm in the same platoon as naomi
thinking about it now won't do me any
good
i have to focus
i should be able to complete the
assignment as long as i'm calm
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
i can annihilate the other with my
psychokinesis
naomi even complimented me on how i was
suited for combat
[Applause]
it's done
next
[Music]
it's done
[Music]
next
[Music]
i wonder if naomi is doing okay
i'm sure she is
she's one of the best
it's done
i heard you took down another major
other oh man i wish i could have fought
with you
it wasn't broadcast this time weren't
the crows there
no a lot was going on
city is really something it's the first
city of new him and the center of the
government and the military
yeah and being here means i won't miss
any information on baki
is that a good thing
[Music]
looks like there's a resource nearby
hit
okay
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
all right
here we go
come on
but it really feels like you're fighting
together
here we go
looks like there's a resource nearby
don't wander off don't go into heavily
damaged areas come on understood i'm
good at reading the air i mean my power
is
after all
that awkward pause was my power too
oh
i have to water the flowers at
headquarters
ah i already did that the seeds we
planted in those pots have sprouted
nice recovery
i know right every household should have
a dependable cargo
let's keep this up looks like the enemy
dropped something rare
here we go
keep this up
[Applause]
[Music]
i think there's something over there you
guys good
damn come on
god
your power is really great
the city vision projectors must be
broken
they're pretty but kind of scary
yeah it's like they're looming up there
here we go
[Music]
let's keep this up
all right
[Music]
[Music]
uh
[Music]
are you okay
being what makes it hard to move
this is pretty
yeah good is
the extinction belt's flow changed
during construction and now a lot of
others appear there
there aren't many powerful others but
everyone should still be careful
[Applause]
are you nervous naomi
your breathing is getting a little
shallow
oh yes a little done but i'm okay
just take a deep breath
you're worried about kasana aren't you
she was worried about you too
you must be close
the enemy is attacking with electricity
you'll be shocked and unable to move if
it hits you
you dropped something rare
i can still fight
i need your help
it's done
[Music]
it's covered in water it'll be easy to
electrify
i see
so that's how you use your psychokinesis
to fight
seems like a reasonably useful power
so
um
i guess we've got no choice
hanabi let's go all right i'm ready
this thing does look pretty tough
yeah we have to have a plan
oh
look up there there's some material
hanging down
use your psychokinesis to slam it down
on its head
okay
[Music]
god here we go
the other is covered in oil so if you
use my power you can turn it into a big
fireball
that's a big
don't get worked up because it's a major
other keep your eyes open
you especially you ito your power lets
you use the things around you don't
focus only on the enemy in front of you
yes sir
here we go
i need to support the injury
is everyone okay
[Music]
yes
[Music]
everyone get back
[Music]
our she looks so different from the way
they present her on tv
she's always lazy when she's not on
camera so a lot of people call her lazy
aura
lazy ara
that suits her perfectly
[Music]
[Music]
yuito want to talk i mean we're on the
same team now
okay but what do you want to talk about
we've known each other since we were
kids you pretty much know everything
about me
uh
you know
huh
i haven't been on a relaxing walk like
this in a while
me neither
i've been on missions constantly since
being assigned
we need to take time for ourselves like
this now and then
so
anyway
can i ask you something
sure
what's up
so
um
what do you think about kasane
huh
why are you suddenly bringing up kasana
well you know we're catching up i wanted
to ask you something that must be on
your mind
and it seems like you've been thinking
about kasane
a lot
you haven't changed at all
really
really i mean you're still into bocky
but i'm a bit happy that you haven't
changed just staying being you
[Music]
beers
so
[Music]
[Music]
you